si le premier cas de kovy 19 n'a été
détectée que le 20 février en italie
le nouveau coronavirus pourrait bien
l'avoir fait son apparition sur le sol
transalpin dès le mois de décembre
dernier
l'institut supérieur de la santé italien
a dévoilé ce mardi une étude établissant
la présence de traces du coc vide 19
dont les eaux usées et à bienne
l'étude a examiné 40 échantillons d'eaux
usées collectées d'octobre 2010 9 à
février 2020 les résultats confirmés
dans deux laboratoires différents avec
deux méthodes différentes ont montré la
présence d' arn sera skov 2 dans les
échantillons prélevés à milan et turin
le 18 décembre 2010 neuf des treize
identiques ont également été trouvés
dans les eaux usées de bologne le 29
janvier dernier
néanmoins tous les tests réalisés sur
des échantillons des mois d'octobre et
novembre dans ces mêmes villes se sont
révélés négatifs
cette recherche peut aider à comprendre
le début de la circulation du virus en
italie et fournit des informations
cohérentes avec d'autres résultats
obtenus à partir de l'analyse
rétrospective des échantillons issus de
patients hospitalisés en france qui a
identifié un échantillons respiratoires
positif ausra scop 2 datant de la fin
décembre 2019 outre la france et
l'italie
des traces du virus ont également été
retrouvées dans des eaux usées de
barcelone en espagne
datant de la mi janvier soit environ 40
jours avant l'identification du premier
cas sur le sol espagnol
à la suite de ces analyses la directrice
du département environnement et santé de
l'institut supérieur de la santé
souhaite surveiller les eaux usées de
tout le pays d'ici à l'automne prochain
nous avons présenté une proposition
d'action au ministère de la santé pour
le lancement d'un réseau de surveillance
de la présence du strass cov 2 dans les
eaux usées nous espérons être prêts pour
la surveillance de l'ensemble du
territoire national dans les périodes
potentiellement les plus critiques de
l'automne prochain la possibilité d'une
deuxième vague de contamination dans les
prochains mois fait de la prudence le
maître mot des autorités le coc vie
19 a fait plus de trente quatre mille
cinq cents morts en italie depuis le
début de l'épidémie